[Music]
despite the passage of 26 years and 11
main entries there has never been a
better time to try Mortal Kombat with a
potent mixture of great tutorials clever
character design and innovative combat
mechanics nether realms newest fighting
game introduces newcomers without
sacrificing depth
it offers separate starting points for
players who prefer story or competition
or customization
simply put Mortal Kombat 11 is a
fighting game for everyone and that's
awesome another realms previous game
2007 teens injustice 2 achieved a
similar effect albeit through different
means
it used DC's brand awareness to bring in
fans of Batman Superman associated
friends and foes before unfurling a huge
loot grind that encouraged
experimentation across several modes it
struck a careful balance between
challenge and accessibility I enjoyed it
so much I made a video about it with
Mortal Kombat 11 it feels as if
NetherRealm took that balance and ran
with it
it displays the hardcore fighting
aspects it's mastered over almost three
decades but conversely it's also the
studio's most accessible title yet I
myself have never been a hardcore
fighting game fan I complete story mode
spend a few nights playing with friends
and usually move on
for me the genre has been a series of
short-term relationships I loved each
game in its own way but I couldn't
commit yet Mortal Kombat 11 hooked me in
a way I did not expect I actively want
to get better this all began as it often
does with the narrative this dumb
fantastical time-bending fire-breathing
spine ripping utterly ridiculous tale of
love loss and how much Kano [ __ ]
sucks
it introduced me to some of my favorite
characters and encouraged me to dig
deeper
it was the pickaxe the Mortal Kombat's
shimmering gold mine shortly after
defeating chronica and her minions
I struck the next layer nether realms
fantastic tutorials they begin with
moves as basic as a front punch or a
back kick before transitioning into -
cancels and flawless blocks before long
I found myself studying frame data and
strategy contrary to most fighting game
tutorials and which I usually give up
once I hit a skill I can't fathom using
in an actual match MK 11 shows me why I
should consider mastering that skill
what's crucial here is that with a
single button press you can practice the
timing of these advanced maneuvers while
MK 11 si I demonstrates them I was this
close to giving up on get up attacks
before I push my touchpad practice the
button timing and soon understood how
useful this skill could be I'm still not
great at pulling them off but I
understand them and this constant
learning gives me a deeper appreciation
for what I already considered a very fun
game I was so engrossed in learning
Mortal Kombat 11s Universal mechanics
that it took me a while to notice its
inclusion of character specific
tutorials these go beyond the standard
practice sessions I normally use to
learn a character they actively explain
a fighter's best functions along with
his or her strengths and weaknesses some
are obvious like Aaron blacks role as as
owner others take a bit more time to
discover such as noob saibot sibility to
use a crushing blow against an enemy
that's blocking high each character is
as complicated as they are flashy and
the tutorials are an excellent way to
explore their layers this brings me to
Mortal Kombat's characters themselves
and I'm actively restraining myself from
going off for another 30 minutes I'm
obsessed with the intricacies of
character design in genres ranging from
first-person shooters to tactical
strategy titles how different fighters
or soldiers factor into the overall flow
of a game how they reinforce its ideas
or transform its systems and Mortal
Kombat Elevens characters are colorful
proof of nether realms design acumen in
a recent video about warframe I explored
the concept of lenticular design it's a
phrase coined by Magic the Gathering
lead designer mark rosewater used to
describe systems that are simultaneously
simple to beginners and complex to
veterans and like warframe MK 11 makes
great use of this practice take scorpion
one of the franchise's most iconic
characters at first blush he's an agile
ninja equipped with katanas and a
grappling hook right away these weapons
make it clear that he can excel at
close-range or from long
distances as you learn him you'll likely
benefit from a combination of both
however once you dig into his special
moves you'll discover his more
supernatural powers namely
flame attacks and teleportation
experience scorpion players will know
how to throw off their enemy by using
his whole moveset sure you can win a
fight just by punching kicking and
swinging your sword but you'll win more
constantly by switching up your
offensive strategy this balance between
obvious abilities and more complicated
and often more useful powers is what
makes scorpion a lenticular character
and it's not just MK Elevens characters
that demonstrate this dichotomy so - -
the new fatal blows these maneuvers give
you a fighting chance when getting your
ass kicked by another player once your
health drops below 30% you gain access
to this powerful attack that melts away
more health than any other one attack in
your fighters arsenal it doesn't
completely level the playing field each
time but it does keep matches
interesting more often than not you also
only get to use one successful fatal
blow per match so when you use it is an
important decision in its own right I've
seen fatal blows compared to Mario karts
infamous blue shells but that's
hyperbolic to say the least
unlike Mario karts a rubber band item
fatal blows don't completely negate the
skill of the best player they merely
bolster that of the weaker or unluckier
one there require thought and strategy
to use correctly
we always talk about character design
and special moves it's time I addressed
Mk 11s loot system which has recently
drawn a lot of criticism and in this
regard nether realm both reinforces and
completely undermines the entire point
of this video so thanks a ton nether
realm on the bright side the fighting
games loot system is yet another way it
brings players into new modes
encouraging them to try the towers of
time or classic challenges and rewarding
them with a continual supply of
cosmetics ability augments and gory
cinematic moves on the not so bright
side if you want them all it takes a
very long time or a lot of money to
unlock everyone this runs completely
against the intelligent systems
throughout the rest of the game ones
that are so good about welcoming new
players and rewarding dedicated ones now
another realm has promised it's working
on fixing the loot system to better
respect players time I hope it does at
its best Mortal Kombat's loot amplifies
the joys of exploring its roster by
unlocking a new cosmetic item for gear
us or a new fatality for cabal the game
entices me to try characters I otherwise
might not as it stands now though MK 11
suite of unlockables feels borderline
predatory and that's a huge bummer
regardless of whether nether realm
actually does improve that aspect of its
newest release I can't help but love
everything else it has to offer for the
first time I'm not only excited to keep
learning a fighting game but almost
every layer of the game is helping me to
do so there are brick walls here and
there when a boss repeatedly destroys me
or when my friend Dan won't stop mashing
his controller and somehow winning no
matter what tactics I use against him
and how much I let my anger feel my
every waking hour getting better so I
can beat him and finally laugh in his
face but this is that rare kind of game
that makes breaking through those walls
fun in almost every layer of its design
Mortal Kombat 11 is a fighting game for
everyone and it's all the better because
of it
you
[Music]